Could you please clarify about the
Surah Waqiah chapter 56 regarding the
touching of the Holy Quran without wudu
and
He wants to know that can we touch the
Quran without wudu and there is a verse
in the Quran Surah Waqiah chapter 56
referring to the verses number 77 to
Can you explain that? But many people
misunderstand that you cannot touch the
Quran without wudu.
This verse of the Quran says in a
nutshell I say, it says that we have
revealed the Quran and none shall touch
the Quran except those who are pure.
Now the word used is mutahharin.
Those are pure. Many people think that
if you are in wudu you become a
mutahharin. Now this purity what the
Quran refers, if you know the background
and the nuzul of Quran when was this
verse revealed, we come to know if you
read the tafsir various tafasir of Ibn
Kathir and other tafasir, we come to
know that there was an allegation that
these verses which the prophet was
receiving, that were being revealed to
him nauzubillah, it was a revelation
from the devil.
So in reply to this allegation Allah
reveals another verse that none shall
touch
the Quran except those who are pure. Now
this purity mutahharin doesn't refer to
only bodily purity.
It refers to pure in mind, in body, in
thinking, absolute 100% masum which no
human being can be.
100%. It is referring to the angels that
no one can touch the Quran except the
angels. That means the devil cannot
interfere in between.
And the Quran referred here is not
referring to the mushaf. This is the
mushaf means the copy of the Quran.
Talking about the Quran in Lawh Mahfuz.
As Allah says about the tablet well
preserved. So that Quran
which is in the heaven
tablet well preserved, no one can come
close to it, no one can touch except the
angels.
Mutahharin mentioned doesn't refer to
only bodily purity. Tahara means only
wudu. It doesn't refer to that. It
refers to absolute purity.
And it doesn't refer to this Quran
refers to the tablet well preserved
in the heaven. If it refers to this
Quran
and it referred to normal wudu, any
non-Muslim can go in the market and
purchase the Quran for 150 rupees easily
and can touch it. That means the Quran
will be proved wrong.
No one can touch it. I can touch it. You
can touch it.
So it is nowhere referring to wudu and
touching this Quran referring to the
absolute purity and about Lawh Mahfuz.
But generally, if someone is in wudu
and touches the Quran, it is preferable.
It is mustahab. It's not a fard.
The scholars differ. There's no verse in
the Quran or hadith which says that wudu
is compulsory for touching the Quran.
Wudu is compulsory for offering salah.
And it was the system of the prophet he
preferred being in wudu always. So it's
not a fard. It's not a requirement you
should be in wudu.
But it is preferable.
There's no verse in the Quran or hadith
which says it is fard. Hope that answers
the question.